vamos con la pregunta número 7 usa la
demostración dada para responder la
pregunta
entonces nos dan que el ángulo 2 es
congruente al ángulo 3 o sea básicamente
que la medida de este ángulo es igual a
la medida de este ángulo de acá y a
partir de ahí queremos mostrar que el
ángulo 1 es congruente al ángulo 4
queremos ver que este ángulo es
congruente a este de acá bueno vamos a
leer la demostración que nos dan el
primer enunciado es que el ángulo 12 es
congruente al ángulo 3 y la razón es que
eso está dado
claro ángulo 2 congruente al ángulo 3 y
eso está dado muy bien el segundo
enunciado es que el ángulo 1 es
congruente al ángulo 2 y que el ángulo
13 es congruente al ángulo 4 vamos a
marcar eso el ángulo 1 es congruente al
ángulo 2 y el ángulo 13 es congruente al
ángulo 4 y aquí tiene un signo de
interrogación entonces yo creo que nos
piden
nos piden dar aquí la razón a ver qué
razón se puede poner para justificar el
enunciado 2 bajado justo queremos dar la
razón que nos permite asegurar que el 1
es congruente al 2 y el 13 es congruente
al 4 creo que eso en inglés se llama
algo así como
verticales pero ahorita no me acuerdo
muy bien de la traducción déjame ver si
alguna de las opciones me recuerda me
recuerda cómo se dice saber entonces a
los complementos de ángulos congruentes
son congruentes no pues eso no es lo que
estamos utilizando realmente ve los
ángulos opuestos opuestos por un vértice
son congruentes si eso suena mucho más a
lo que queremos verdad el 1 y el 2 son
opuestos por este vértice y entonces
deben de ser congruentes déjame encerrar
esto en una cajita para ponerlo como un
buen candidato c los suplementos de
ángulos congruentes son congruentes
bueno es cierto pero pero no es lo que
estamos usando y de ángulos
correspondientes son congruentes no
tampoco es eso ángulos correspondientes
son por ejemplo el 1 y el 3 no el 1 y el
2 entonces yo me iría por la b pero para
estar totalmente seguro déjame buscarlo
en internet voy a abrir por acá voy
abrir google
está google y ahora déjame buscar déjame
buscar ángulos
los opuestos por el vértice que mira
wikipedia es la primera página deja fija
lo pasó aquí a la pantalla
la pantalla ok esto dice wikipedia
wikipedia dice en geometría euclidiana
dadas dos rectas r&s del plano que se
cortan en el punto p punto p dos ángulos
se dicen opuestos por el vértice cuando
los lados de uno son semi rectas
opuestas a los lados del otro y mucha
más tecnología terminología sofisticada
vamos a ver el ejemplo mejor en la
figura los ángulos hace hace y ve de bd
son opuestos por el vértice de dos
ángulos opuestos por el vértice son
congruentes y eso es justo lo que
queremos verdad como hice eso es justo
lo que sucede lo que sucede aquí en en
nuestro problema con el ángulo el ángulo
1 y el ángulo 2 entonces si la opción es
b los ángulos opuestos por un vértice
son congruentes muy bien vamos a pasar
al siguiente problema
dice dice dos rectas en un plano siempre
se intersectan en exactamente un punto
ok
cuál de las siguientes describe el mejor
contra ejemplo para la afirmación previa
vamos a pensar un poco antes de ver las
opciones a ver entonces cuando sucede
que dos rectas no se intersectan en
exactamente un punto bueno pues un
ejemplo que se me ocurre es tener dos
rectas paralelas por ejemplo si esta
recta es paralela a esta de acá entonces
estas dos rectas no se intersectan esto
es básicamente la definición de que dos
rectas sean paralelas no que no se
intersectan o bueno que tengan la misma
dirección pero si tienen la misma
dirección y no son la misma entonces en
el plano no se intersecta va entonces
ese sería un ejemplo y otro ejemplo que
se me ocurre es tomar dos rectas
encimadas una en la otra por ejemplo
podemos tomar esa recta bueno a lo mejor
para ti eso no son dos rectas eso puede
estar a discusión pero pudiéramos tomar
esas dos rectas y entonces no se
intersectan en exactamente un punto sino
en toda la recta pero bueno vamos a ver
si alguno de estos dos ejemplos está
está aquí en las opciones rectas
coplanar es no ves rectas paralelas y
este es el que estoy diciendo aquí
arriba verdad rectas paralelas se de
rectas perpendiculares no y de rectas
intersectan test pues puede ser un poco
esto pero creo que ve es un mejor contra
ejemplo vale rectas paralelas entonces
la respuesta sería ve ahora vamos al
problema número nueve
dice si un par de lados opuestos de un
cuadrilátero son paralelos entonces el
cuadrilátero es un paralelogramo otra
vez muchos términos creo que se ve un
patrón verdad al parecer en estas
preguntas les gusta les gusta mucho pues
hablar de definiciones entonces vamos a
vamos a platicar un poco de cuadrilátero
cuadrilátero simplemente es una figura
de cuatro lados y de paralelogramo
paralelogramo es una figura en la cual
los pares de lados opuestos son
paralelos y van a es un cuadrilátero
entonces sería más o menos algo así
tendríamos ese lado este lado de acá en
este lado de acá lo voy a hacer un poco
más largo
y finalmente este lado de acá quizás
debía haber hecho un poco más largo este
como por ahí sale entonces ahí tenemos
un paralelogramo porque esta es paralela
a estar acá esta línea es paralela esta
línea y esta es paralela a esta de acá y
bueno si este paralelogramo tuviera sus
cuatro lados iguales entonces se
llamaría se llamaría un rombo pero bueno
vamos a ver vamos a ver qué dice cuál
figura puede servir como contraejemplo
para la conjetura previa esta de aquí
arriba pues vamos a pensarlo otra vez
antes de ver las opciones que
necesitamos necesitamos una figura que
tenga un par de lados opuestos paralelos
pero que no sea un paralelogramo y que
además sea un cuadrilátero bueno pues a
mí se me ocurre algo de este estilo
podemos poner aquí un lado
podemos poner aquí arriba a un lado
paralelo a este de aquí abajo y podemos
unir este este extremo con este y este
extremo con este y listo tenemos un
cuadrilátero en el cual este lado es
paralelo a este pero este no es paralelo
a este y por lo tanto no es un
paralelogramo ya una figura así se le
llama trapecio
aprecio trapecio vamos a ver si está en
las opciones rectángulo no rombo no
cuadrado no trapecio aquí está trapecio
muy bien de hecho a veces no son contra
ejemplos porque tanto los rectángulos
como los rombos como los cuadrados son
paralelo gramos el rectángulo tiene
todos los ángulos de 90 grados entonces
los lados opuestos son paralelos el
rombo tiene sus cuatro lados iguales y
se puede ver que a partir de eso éste
los lados son paralelos los lados
opuestos y el cuadrado pues es un
rectángulo un rectángulo en el cual los
cuatro lados son iguales y por lo tanto
también es paralelogramo entonces éstas
no nos sirven muy bien vamos a vamos a
pasar ahora el problema 10 dice dado que
tr
es un trapecio isósceles con diagonal
srp y thea cuál de las siguientes debe
ser ciertas otra vez más terminología
tenemos un trapecio isósceles yo creo
que eso se refiere a un trapecio en el
cual en el cual los lados que no son la
base y la parte de arriba miden lo mismo
es decir este lado y este lado que no
son paralelos
me den lo mismo en realidad hace mucho
que no veo la definición de trapecio
isósceles pero para no buscar en
internet vamos a suponer que es eso de
hecho es una buena habilidad una buena
habilidad de eso de poder descubrir a
qué se refieren cuando cuando hablan de
una cierta figura bueno entonces en el
trapecio isósceles este lado mide lo
mismo que éste y este de acá es paralelo
a este de acá
nos dicen que rp y tea son las
diagonales entonces aquí le voy a poner
r quiero va a poner mejor t que iba a
poner r por acá a la caja y finalmente
por aquí nos dicen que te hay cierre y
rp son las diagonales las voy a pintar
ok entonces aquí ya está nuestra figura
y de aquí podemos empezar a pensar
algunas cosas que nos preguntan entonces
cuál de las siguientes debe ser cierta o
sea siempre es cierta a ver
rp es perpendicular a tea el segmento de
rp es perpendicular al segmento tea
bueno aquí como lo dibujé pues podría
ser que si no o sea uno podría decir que
parece que son perpendiculares pero será
eso siempre cierto pues yo creo que yo
creo que no porque por ejemplo
pudiéramos acercarte r hacia pea
dejándolo así paralelo éste lo vamos
moviendo hacia abajo y hacia abajo y
hacia abajo y como no nos dicen cuál es
la altura pues observemos que este
ángulo que es igual esté acá porque son
opuestos por el vértice como ya
aprendimos se va haciendo cada vez más y
más flaco entonces aunque aquí sea de 90
esta recta este ángulo se va a ser más y
más chiquito y entonces no siempre
tenemos que las diagonales son son
perpendiculares entonces éste no déjame
tacharlo esta opción no ve rp es
paralela atea
rp es paralela tea no eso es ridículo
son diagonales se intersectan en un
punto y por lo tanto no pueden ser
paralelas entonces éste tampoco es a ver
rp es congruente ate a rpp es congruente
ate a estos dos segmentos miden lo mismo
eso se ve mucho más prometedor verdad
por la simetría de esta figura si
trazáramos por aquí una línea vertical
más o menos algo de este estilo entonces
tenemos simetría éste con respecto a
esta línea y pues suena muy razonable
que éste sea igual a este perdón que
éste sea igual a éste que éste sea igual
a éste y entonces que las diagonales me
dan lo mismo pero a lo mejor sería bueno
dar un argumento un poco más un poco más
formal déjame borrar la línea de
simetría y lo vamos a hacer de la
siguiente forma esta es una prueba
clásica y por eso me sale tan rápido lo
que voy a hacer es bajar bajar
perpendiculares desde
r ap entonces aquí es perpendicular aquí
es perpendicular como t es paralela a
pea entonces aquí es perpendicular aquí
es perpendicular y aquí adentro también
entonces si este se llama xy este se
llama y tenemos que te x r es un
rectángulo y como es un rectángulo
tenemos que este lado de acá es igual a
este lado de acá miden lo mismo te x es
congruente aire y pero entonces ahora
los triángulos txp y r
ambos son rectángulos tienen la misma
hipotenusa porque el trapecio es
isósceles y tienen este cateto
compartido tienen este lado que mide
igual a este lado por lo tanto tenemos
que el triángulo el triángulo t xp es
congruente al triángulo r
el rey estoy aquí estoy aquí es por
criterio por criterio el de ángulo
rectángulo se llama de triángulo
rectángulo se llama recto lado
hipotenusa vale bueno pero a partir de
esta congruencia a partir de esta
congruencia se puede concluir que el
ángulo t px
escurre es congruente al correspondiente
o sea el ere h
congruente a este de acá y ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es fijarnos en otros dos
triángulos déjame marcar los vamos a
fijarnos en el t p a este de aquí y ese
es el o vamos a comparar con con el r
r muy bien o se observa que ahora estos
dos triángulos tienen el lado tp igual
al lado r a tiene en el lado pea igual a
sí mismo y además tienen estos dos
ángulos morados congruentes y este
ángulo morado es el ángulo entre el pp y
el pea y el área y el ape entonces ahora
por criterio por criterio lado ángulo
lado tenemos que son congruentes tenemos
voy a poner aquí el triángulo t que es
congruente al área p
el triángulo r
por criterio lado ángulo lado muy bien y
eso está padre porque a partir de esta
congruencia podemos concluir que las
diagonales las diagonales del trapecio
que son estos lados correspondientes en
la congruencia de triángulos tea y erp
son iguales vale bueno entonces eso
prueba que ese es la opción correcta
pero finalmente vamos a ver qué dice d
vamos a ver qué dice de nada más para no
dejarla y abandonada de nos dice rp be
seca
rp y seca atea pues no verdad
incluso en este trapecio que dibuje se
ve clarito que este segmento de acá mide
mide distinto que este segmento de acá
entonces las diagonales no se dice que
vale las diagonales no se cortan a la
mitad entonces de es incorrecta muy bien
vamos a dejarle aquí nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo para continuar con el
problema número 11